[Music]
in recent days there has been a lot of
speculation surrounding the production
of the third season of the mandalorian
as a said employee posted a picture via
instagram announcing the end of shooting
when the post was deleted shortly
thereafter it only further fueled the
rumors about the conclusion meanwhile
though it has become official as grief
cargo actor called weathers finally
shared an image on twitter that
confirmed the fans speculations still
unclear however all the exact cast and
plot of season 3 known are the
aforementioned weathers giancarlo
esposito asmof gideon and of course
pedro pascal as the eponymous
mandalorian the solo newcomer is back to
the future star christopher lloyd as we
already reported two weeks ago sadly it
is not yet confirmed as to when we can
expect the new season to launch on
disney plus the situation is different
for the upcoming obi-wan kenobi series
which is scheduled for release at the
end of may as ewan mcgregor announced in
a recent statement however the series
will not be released on may 25th as
previously planned but two days later on
may 27th on disney plus many fans are
particularly excited about the confirmed
appearance of hayden christensen as
anakin skywalker who has not been
featured in these roles in star wars
episode 3 revenge of the sith back in
2005. most recently you supposed leak
made the rounds on reddit allegedly
showing secret footage of a dwell
between obi-wan and his former padawan
anakin the fact that the video was
leaked on april 1st doesn't really speak
for the authenticity of the short clip
yet the footage looks surprisingly
realistic one clue in favor of
authenticity is at least darth vader's
outfit which is identical to the
official image and entertainment weekly
published on march 10th and even in
other respects it would probably have to
be a very elaborate fake what do you
guys think is the video real or is it a
clear fake in your opinion let us know
in the comments either way you will be
able to watch the first two episodes of
the new obi-wan kenobi series on disney
plus starting may 27
2022 fans of the witcher we're happy to
get an announcement about the third
season this week as the official twitter
account revealed based on two pictures
the production is well underway one
image shows the filming set in a snowy
location while the other one presents
the first official synopsis of this
season geralt will get into dangerous
ground to protect siri and his reunited
family joining him is jennifer who's
tasked with siri's magical training and
therefore accompanies her to the
fortress of aratuza which we already
know from the two existing seasons as we
are used to from the books the topics of
betrayal corruption and scheming will
also be of great importance returning in
front of the camera are henry cavill as
the witcher gerald anja calatra as
jennifer and freya allen as siri
unfortunately there is no official
launch date yet but a release prior to
the end of next year seems extremely
unrealistic
thor love and thunder will be released
in theaters on july 8th 2022 fans have
not yet had the chance to watch a
trailer which is beginning to seem
somewhat suspicious giving that the
movie will be released in about three
months of all things an image taken from
a spanish tweet is now set to reveal the
date of the first trailer a report from
comicbook.com remarks that the fingers
of the stars pictured make 11 4 and 22
from left to right if that's what taika
white hidey chris hemsworth and tessa
thompson had in mind we can expect the
trailer to be released very soon on
monday april 11th whether this is indeed
the case is something you will soon be
able to find out for yourself
last year the south korean netflix
series quit game suddenly became one of
the most popular and successful series
of all time after the relatively open
end of season one squid game creator
huangdong hill shared his thoughts on
the planned start of the new season in
an interview at the annual mip tv in cam
thus the new season is expected to begin
at the end of 2024 if everything works
out as planned he has already completed
the first pages of the script and is
currently in the middle of the creative
period of the screenplay along the way
he's also working on killing old people
club his new movie which is supposed to
live up to its name with boundless
brutality that reportedly exceeds even
that of squid game naturally not much is
known about the plot of the new squid
game season yet but in this regard we
can recommend our squid game original
where we introduce you to the most
exciting possibilities we will gladly
keep you up to date on further news
about the next season
a veritable sherlock holmes hype
dominated film and television between
2009 and 2017. first there was the
famous series starring vanity
cumberbatch that ran from 2010 to 2017
and second the two movies starring
robert downey jr and the role of the
master detective were released in 2009
and 2011. as variety now reports downey
jr and his wife susan are working with
hbo max on two series at once both
spin-off series are set to introduce a
new character and function independently
of downey jr's holmes and jude laws
watson as of yet there is no additional
info on the two series all that is known
is that the characters appearing in this
series will make their first appearance
in a third sherlock holmes movie
starring robert downey jr the latter was
supposed to have been released in movie
theaters in 2020 but was then postponed
and eventually shelved but now with a
new announcement of the two spin-offs
we're glad to see that things are moving
forward again regarding the third
sherlock holmes film the upcoming
sherlock holmes project do not have any
release dates yet
due to movies like we need to talk about
kevin and fantastic beasts as ramilla
became the hollywood star he is today in
the past though miller really stood out
for positive publicity they were
recurring issues related to drugs and
drinking and he was considered an
extremely difficult individual to deal
with behind the scenes this was also
evident from several escapades to which
miller allowed himself in the past in
april 2020 the video circulates on the
29 year old assaulting a woman which
already caused some controversy at the
time when johnny depp was being
dismissed nevertheless he was allowed to
stay on both fantastic beasts and the
flesh surely also because an exclusion
from one would have met an exclusion
from all other wanna projects but when
miller was then arrested on march 28
2022 following an altercation with a man
and a woman and even went so far as to
threaten the couple after his release it
seems that for warner this was the last
straw that broke the camel's back as
rolling stone reports warner decided on
how to proceed in emergency meeting
which resulted in putting all projects
with miller on hold for the studio this
is a great solution because it allows
them to wait and see how much the flash
brings in at the box office nonetheless
miller's expulsion could have far
reaching impact on the rest of the dcu
since the film like spider-man away home
in the mcu serves to open up a
multiverse particularly awkward is the
fact that the flash and miller's
performance are said to have been very
well received in test screenings fans
show little sympathy following the
accusation against the actor and demand
a replacement by grant gustin the star
of the flash series well in any case we
are eager to see what ezra miller's
future at warner brothers will look like
the flash is expected to run in theaters
from june 23 2023
star trek picard charana terry metallis
recently announced in a press release
that the upcoming third season of the
series will be the final one moreover
there was the big news of a reunion of
familiar faces from star trek the next
generation thus all the important
characters from the series which started
in 1987 are expected to return including
in addition to patrick stewart level
burton as jody leforge michael dornis
wharf jonathan frakes says commander
riker gates mcfadden's dr crutcher
marina certais as diana troy and bran
spiner as the android data some of the
actors already made the one or other
appearance in season 1 and 2 of star
trek picard but now they are actually
all supposed to get back together we are
excited about further details and look
forward to the third season which
unfortunately does not have a fixed
release date yet
we hope you enjoyed our video on this
week's news if interested we highly
suggest you watch the new trailer for dr
strange and the multiverse of madness on
our channel as the movie is about to hit
theaters soon on may 6th wish you a
lovely weekend see you next week
oh
[Music]